Пане Максиме, дякую, що ви погодилися на інтерв'ю.
У Брюсселі часто говорять про
необхідність проведення приватизації в Україні.
І уряд також багато обіцяв, великі були плани,
у січні ухвалили закон про приватизацію.
Коли і з чого розпочнеться приватизація?
Справді, приватизація є одним з пріоритетів уряду,
і справді, це одна зі сфер, в якій ми показали не дуже багато прогресу з 2014 року.
Саме для цього ми і змінюємо приватизаційний процес.
Ми ухвалили новий закон про приватизацію, я вдячний Верховній Раді
і президенту за його підписання.
Ми сподіваємося, що наступного тижня будуть опубліковані
останні підзаконні акти для нього.
Це означає, що перші аукціони з так званої "малої приватизації",
тобто всі об'єкти, окрім 50 найбільших,
почнуть оголошуватися з кінця червня.
У той же щодо топ-50 великих об'єктів
уряд нещодавно затвердив перелік перших, які підуть на приватизацію.
Ми очікуємо, що першою компанією,
яка буде готова до цього, буде "Центренерго".
Там вже працює радник.
Людей часто цікавить, хто ж є "поганими хлопцями".
Українські ЗМІ публікували інформацію про те, що
Рінату Ахметову тепер може бути цікавим повернення "Укртелекому"
у власність держави.
Багато говорять про роль Фірташа довкола ОПЗ.
Верховна Рада начебто вже ухвалила закон.
Хто ж тоді "погані хлопці"?
Фонд держмайна, олігархи, уряд?
Приватизація - одна з найскладніших реформ,
бо вона справді ламає дуже багато інтересів.
По-перше, є загальний філософський популізм.
На жаль, велика кількість виборців в Україні,
велика кількість стейкхолдерів і в уряді, і в парламенті
все ще знаходяться в якійсь парадигмі Радянського Союзу,
коли держава має бути величезною,
має керувати кожною галуззю від металургії до метрології та стандартизації,
і продавати будь-що не можна або до цього можна ставитися виключно як
до того, що це якісь золоті зливки, які ми по одному, якщо дуже треба,
дістаємо з серванту та продаємо.
Також кожне підприємство обліплене різноманітними інтересами.
Дуже часто керівники цих підприємств, коли ти намагаєшся їх змінити, кажуть: "А нас за що?".
Вони вважають, що це фактично їхня приватна власність.
І вони де-факто є не юридичними, але якимись формальними власниками цих об'єктів.
Звичайно, на жаль, тут є і питання політичної корупції,
бо якщо ми кажемо про об'єкти великої приватизації,
то ми кажемо про досить суттєві кошти,
які розкрадаються і через закупівлі,
і через продаж за заниженими цінами,
і через часто недоцільні капітальні інвестиції.
Тільки НАБУ розслідує близько 50 справ
із потенційною сумою збитків, що перевищує 20 мільярдів гривень.
Приблизно такі самі обсяги тих проваджень, які є у Генеральної прокуратури,
а ще є СБУ й інші правоохоронні органи, тому, повірте, там є за що поборотися.
Ви кажете про те, що необхідно змінювати свідомість.
В України три-чотири тисячі держпідприємств.
Багато з них не приносять прибутку або не працюють,
завдаючи лиш збитки. Скільки з них є сенс приватизувати, а скільки краще ліквідувати?
Ну, власне, тільки під Кабінетом міністрів України
перебувають близько 3450 держпідприємств.
З них близько половини не працюють,
фактично вони є кандидатами на банкрутство,
але це аж ніяк не означає, що там немає того, що продавати.
Скоріше навпаки, це великі можливості для інвестицій.
Це ділянки землі з усіма комунікаціями і з електрикою,
з залізничним сполученням, це якась нерухомість,
яка може бути використана потенційним інвестором, який хоче
швидко розгорнути там виробництво.
Якщо ж ми кажемо про об'єкти, які недоцільно приватизовувати,
принаймні в якомусь середньостроковому майбутньому,
це, звичайно, ті об'єкти, які або мають стратегічне значення для держави,
необхідні для забезпечення енергетичної безпеки і так далі,
або ті об'єкти, де ринок не готовий поки взяти на себе всю відповідальність.
Наприклад, у Японії
є атомні електростанції, які належать приватним власникам.
Але зрозуміло, що в Україні і нормативно, і технологічно,
і з бізнес-логіки має пройти ще багато десятків років,
якщо ми тільки зважимося на такий крок.
Ви раніше казали, що хотіли би повернутися в бізнес.
Можете трохи детальніше розказати про ваші подальші плани?
Ну звичайно, з точки зору людини, яка прийшла в державний апарат зовні,
робота тут є досить важкою.
Це не тільки питання зарплати,
не тільки питання інколи складних умов праці,
але, звичайно, і вміння якось
балансувати інтересами, бо якщо в бізнесі в тебе є компанія,
у компанії є конкретна ціль і вся компанія працює на цю ціль,
якщо хтось не бажає працювати або саботує цю роботу,
таку людину або депреміюють, або вчать, або, зрештою, звільняють,
у державних структурах такий шлях часто є неможливим.
Але, з іншого боку, я завжди повторюю, що
зараз у нас є унікальне вікно можливостей.
Реформи не можна робити весь час - і 10 років тому, і зараз, і ще за 20 років.
Все побудовано в житті, як і в бізнесі,
на якихось можливостях, якими ми, в даному випадку як нація,
скористаємося, або не скористаємося.
Зараз будувати новий Facebook вже пізно.
Якби Марк Цукерберг прийшов з такою ідею 30 років тому,
точно було би ще зарано.
Тому я всіх і запрошую максимально долучатися
до процесу реформ і йти працювати на державу, допомагати державі -
як волонтери, як держслужбовці, як працівники якихось команд реформ,
які фінансуються донорами, тому що мені здається, що
саме зараз у України є можливість реально перевигадати країну.
А ви не думали піти в політику, щоб звідти більше сприяти реформам?
Ми знаємо приклад людини, яка була інвестбанкіром,
потім у міністерстві економіки, а потім стала президентом Франції.
Вас не надихає приклад Макрона, канцлера Австрії Курца, прем'єра Канади Трюдо?
Я думаю, що в кожної людини є якісь сильні та слабкі здібності.
Мені здається, мої навички, мій характер і мій стиль управління
точно більше підходять до кар'єри менеджера.
Мені здається, що я непогано справляюся з тим, що я роблю, -
створюю нові системи або просуваю реформи там, де вони потрібні.
Нам і нашій команді вдалося створити ProZorro,
вдалося створити ProZorro.Продажі,
вдається просувати дерегуляцію, де Україна стрибнула
на 20 місць у рейтингу Doing Business, і так далі.
Для того, аби працювати політиком, потрібні якісь інші навички,
напевно, більше комунікабельності,
більше вміння домовлятися з людьми, більше бажання бути в софітах телекамер.
Принаймні, поки що для себе я не розглядаю таку можливість.
Ви згадали про ProZorro, це ваше дітище.
Вона вже вийшла на якийсь самодостатній рівень, коли може існувати без вашого опікування?
Чи ви бачите щось, що варто далі розвивати, покращувати, якісь, може, нові функції?
ProZorro серед тих проектів, якими ми займаємося,
перебуває на досить зрілій стадії.
Вона вже є самоокупною,
не вимагає постійних вкладень грошей зі сторони донорів
і вона вже довела свою ефективність.
Але це не якась програма на кшталт офісного пакета,
який ви інсталювали собі на ноутбук і просто працюєте.
ProZorro - це технічна оболонка тієї реформи публічних закупівель, яку ми робимо.
У нас ще багато в планах - як з точки зору того, що ми не доробили,
так і інтеграції нашого законодавства з вимогами ЄС.
Наприклад, зараз ми працюємо над переведенням усього процесу в безпаперовий формат.
Це означає і автоматичне підключення до реєстрів,
і електронний контрактинг, і електронні платежі.
Ми багато працюємо над електронним ризик-менеджментом.
Який сенс генерувати кожного місяця два-три терабайти даних,
якщо ви з ними нічого не робите?
І навпаки: ми хочемо, аби кожну закупівлю перевіряла не людина, яка,
на жаль, може бути суб'єктивна або має корупційні ризики,
а щоб її перевіряв алгоритм
із правилами і ставив червоний прапорець,
якщо ми бачимо ризик і він потребує втручання правоохоронних органів.
Тому працювати там, звичайно, є багато над чим.
А стосовно планів на майбутнє,
півтора року тому ми стартували ProZorro.Продажі -
таку саму систему, як і ProZorro в закупівлях,
але зі зворотною логікою, яка орієнтована
на анонімні аукціони на підвищення ціни.
Ця система вже продала державного і комунального майна
більше, ніж на 8,5 мільярдів гривень.
Власне кажучи, через неї зараз і починається мала приватизація.
Ми дуже сподіваємося, що через неї піде майбутня оренда і продаж сільськогосподарської землі.
Тому планів у нас ще багатенько.
Щодо малих і середніх підприємств:
в ЄС багато кажуть про підтримку, про розвиток.
Я так розумію, тут і співпраця йде з ЄС.
Ви б могли детальніше розповісти?
Ми дуже сподіваємося, що політика з підтримки малого і середнього бізнесу
справді стане одним зі стовпів розвитку економіки України у 2018-2019 роках.
Уряд багато чого може зробити в цій сфері.
Ми нещодавно ухвалили стратегію розвитку і плани на найближче майбутнє.
Вони забуються на кількох принципах. Перший - інформаційний.
Ми хочемо дати людям просту інформацію про те,
як розпочати бізнес, як зареєструвати, як платити податки, як експортувати та імпортувати і т. д.
Вже зараз створено велику кількість онлайн-інструкцій,
побудованих за принципом сценаріїв: "я хочу відкрити кафе",
і далі просто сайт проводить вас за певним алгоритмом.
Ви хочете продавати алкоголь чи ні? Ви відкриваєте його у власному приміщенні чи орендованому?
Другий блок - це звичайно фінансова підтримка.
Зрозуміло, що у будь-якого нового бізнесмена постає питання, де взяти гроші.
Ми не можемо відповісти кожному на це питання,
Власне кажучи, якоїсь нескінченної кількості дешевих грошей у нас немає.
Але ми активно розробляємо якраз разом і з ЄС,
і зі Світовим банком концепцію часткових портфельних гарантій.
Це коли держава дає гарантію не на конкретний кредит - на кав'ярню чи перукарню.
Тому що, зрозуміло, з ним важко працювати, його важко оцінювати.
а коли держава гарантує цілий портфель кредитів - тисячу, дві, десять тисяч кредитів,
знижуючи таким чином відсоткову ставку для позичальника.
Третій аспект - регіональна мережа.
Навіть я особисто відповідаю кожного дня на, інколи, 10-20 запитів, на досить тривіальні питання.
Ми розуміємо, що це означає, що в людей немає якогось іншого ресурсу,
іншого місця, де вони можуть спитати.
Я не є прихильником, аби наймати більше держслужбовців, аби відповідати на ці запитання,
і ми хочемо використовувати вже наявну мережу центрів надання адміністративних послуг.
Їх в Україні більше 800, і ми хочемо, аби в тих з них, які потужні,
які знаходяться в економічно привабливих регіонах, сиділи власне бізнес-консультанти,
які, з одного боку, відповідали б на питання підприємців, а з іншого боку
збирали б для нас як для регулятора, як для міністерства економіки типові проблеми,
з якими ми маємо боротись.
І четверте, але не останнє, - це питання інклюзивного бізнесу.
Це питання того, аби допомогти тим категоріям громадян,
яким держава хоче надати більшу підтримку.
Це можуть бути внутрішньо переміщені особи, люди з інвалідністю, жіноче підприємництво.
Тобто, ті категорії населення, яким ми хочемо давати не рибу у вигляді соціальних платежів,
а ми хочемо дати їм вудку і навчити заробляти на життя.
А роль Німеччини - механізм гарантування кредитів. Ви могли б детальніше про це розповісти?
Я дуже вдячний уряду Німеччини і міністерству з розвитку, і організації KfW, з якими ми і працюємо
над тим, аби запустити цей проект
У нас є німецько-український фонд, який був започаткований в Україні
ще колишнім канцлером Гельмутом Колем,
який з того часу займається кредитуванням малого і середнього бізнесу.
Цю інституцію ми з допомогою німецьких партнерів і хочемо переорієнтувати з власне кредитування,
яке має певні обмеження, тому що є валютні ризики.
Навіть ті кошти, які наші партнери, у тому числі з Європи, з Німеччини, виділяють на це.
Вони їх виділяють у євро, кредити видаються в українській гривні,
і хтось має взяти на себе валютний ризик, тоу дуже дешевими вони виходити фізично не можуть.
І саме цю інституцію ми й хочемо перенаправити саме на ось такі портфельні гарантії.
Зараз ідуть активні переговори, і я сподіваюся,
що до кінця цього року такі гарантії в пілотному режимі вже будуть видані.
Зрозуміло. Ще питання інвестицій. Минулого року було бажання
провести велику міжнародну конференцію з інвестицій.
Це не вдалося.
Є певні поодинокі приклади - приходять інвестори, наприклад, та ж сама Head -
виробник спортивного обладнання - оголосила, що вони хочуть
відкрити виробництво в Україні.
Скажіть, будь ласка, чи змінилося вже щось у сприйнятті за кордоном України?
Чи досі війна і, у першу чургу, корупція відлякують інвесторів?
Звичайно, ми не задоволені абсолютним рівнем і ми маємо робити значно більше,
але позитивна динаміка точно вражає.
Минулого року обсяг капітальних інвестицій в країні зріс більше ніж на 22 відсотки.
Цього року ми провели якраз успішну інвестиційну конференцію в Києві
За місяць буде інвестиційний форум у Копенгагені, тобто, цей процес набирає обертів.
Що ми можемо зробити для цього як уряд?
У першу чергу створити зрозумілі правила, за якими будуть грати інвестори.
Ми подали у парламент - уже пройшов перше читання - законопроект про концесії.
Ми очікуємо на його схвалення до вересня. І очікуємо, що три перші об'єкти,
серед яких два порти, можуть піти в концесію до кінця цього року.
Ми дуже задоволені роботою, у тому числі з німецькими виробниками автозапчастин
і різноманітними іншими компаніями стосовно створення автомобільного кластеру -
зараз іде активна робота щодо цього - з центром у Львові.
Ми ведемо переговори з Volkswagen стосовно можливості
відкриття збирального виробництва в Україні.
Тобто, цей процес триває.
Ще раз кажу, звичайно, з абсолютної точки зору хочеться набагато більшого,
але будь-яка дорога починається з першого кроку.
І ми точно пройшли тут не один, не два і навіть не п'ять кроків.
Скажіть , будь ласка, ще
- ініціатива "Купуй українське". Ви виступали проти ухвалення цього закону,
бо він - Ви казали - суперечить ЗВТ з ЄС.
Скажіть, будь ласка, що натомість Ви пропонуєте для підтримки купівлі української продукції?
Досвід будь-якої країни доводить, що використовувати систему національних закупівель,
аби роздувати комусь якісь преференції, - це абсолютно нелогічна і непродумана справа.
Мова не тільки про те, що це суперечить вимогам угоди про асоціацію або угоди про вільну торгівлю
у рамках Світової організації торгівлі.
Мова йде про те, що це просто абсолютно економічно недоцільно.
Тому що пропонується видавати якісь преференції нецільові - ми не розуміємо,
кому вони будуть дані, які не є якимось чином контрольованими.
Тобто, нам буде дуже важко сказати: "Ми витратили більше грошей з державного бюджету,
і що ми отримали після цього".
І, нарешті, у них немає жодного конкретного механізму використання
Ми просто даємо людям більше грошей, сподіваючись,
що вони витратять їх не на яхти чи дорогі автомобілі, а на розширення виробництва.
Тому практика у більшості країн, в тому числі й Німеччини, базується на тому,
що ми маємо у публічних закупівлях виступати за максимальну конкуренцію.
А якщо ми хочемо підтримувати національний бізнес, а, звичайно, я хочу,
ми маємо робити конкретні цільові програми з такої підтримки.
І ось якраз такі програми як щодо портфельних гарантій, які я називав,
вони саме й мають спрацювати значно краще, тому що ми будемо розуміти,
скільки коштів виділяється з бюджету на такі гарантії.
Ми будемо розуміти, яке банківське плече в результаті отримано,
тобто, скільки грошей отримав реальний бізнес.
І після цього за рік ми зможемо чітко оцінити, чи призвело це до збільшення зайнятості.
Чи призвело це до збільшення експорту. Чи призвело це збільшення ВВП.
Відповідно, депутати зможуть зробити свідомий вибір.
Якщо ці програми класно працюють, значить, давайте збільшувати їх фінансування.
Якщо вони працюють погано, то, значить, треба щось модернізувати в цьому механізмі.
На таких принципах ми і намагаємося базувати всю економічну політику -
не на просто лозунгах і популізмі, а на чомусь,
що можна порахувати і привести до математики.
І останнє коротке запитання.
Разом з вами після Революції гідності прийшло доволі багато реформаторів й іноземців в уряд,
на державну службу, але потім немало хто пішов звідти.
Скажіть, будь ласка, чи відчувається це або
чи відчуваєте Ви зміну в сприйнятті на державній службі, що стало більше реформаторського підходу?
Це нормальний процес - хтось приходить на робооту, хтось втомлюється, хтось іде з державної служби.
Я вже розповідав, що це не та робота, яку люди часто уявляють собі як роботу мрії.
Я завжди, коли рекламую цю роботу, навпаки розповідаю,
що у вас є можливість працювати криголамом і створювати щось нове,
у чого є шанс увійти в підручники історії.
Але криголамом працювати важко.
Так само, як і ви намагаєтесь пробити кригу,
так само і крига, напевно, намагається зламати вас.
Але ми точно бачимо, що ініціатива, у тому числі з громадянського суспільства, зберігається.
Звичайно, хтось їде, наприклад, той самий Олександр Стародубцев,
який насправді є батьком ProZorro,
і який створив цю історію. Він поїхав вчитися в Стенфорд,
але планує повернутися і продовжувати підтримувати реформи.
Його місце зайняли якісь інші люди, яких ми наймали, наприклад, з ІТ-сектору.
Такі як Василь Задворний, нинішній керівник державного підприємства ProZorro,
які прийшли з новими навичками і новими технологіями, і підсилюють команду.
Тому я не хотів би якось драматизувати цей процес,
а навпаки хотів би використати цю можливість, аби сказати,
зараз у державі є унікальні можливості з проведення змін.
І мені здається, що стояти осторонь і принаймні не спробувати щось змінити,
точно пройде 20-30 років, і та людина, яка стояла осторонь,
вона про це пошкодує.
Пане Максиме, я Вам дуже дякую за інтерв'ю.